2021 saw more bank branches closed than
any other year in the last seven years
that's right your financial institution
they're shutting down the physical
locations it's 2022 now we live in the
digital age what the hell are people
doing with all these bank branches well
as you can see since 2014 there's been
about a thousand to about 2 000 bank
branches that have been shut down every
single year but last year the year after
the pandemic started we hit almost 3 000
total bank branches being closed most of
these bank branches are being seen as a
way to consolidate cost the banks
they're not as profitable when they run
all of these different bank branches
each bank can save about 250 000 when
they shut down one of these branches but
they still got to be able to serve their
customers and so it's a constant balance
should we shut down the bank branch or
should we actually save money what you
can see is that if you actually break
down buy bank who's shutting down the
bank branches you find that wells fargo
they're one of the big culprits they
shut down 267 bank branches themselves
huntington bank shares closed about 221
which is the most on a percentage basis
because they only had about a thousand
bank branches to begin with and then of
course if we go ahead and we look at a
map of the united states you can see
that the net bank branch openings and
closings across the united states of
course if you want to get positive
there's only two or three states in the
entire country that actually had a net
positive gain to the number of bank
branches but places like california
florida and new york losing tons and
tons of bank branches it's not
necessarily something you should be
surprised by given how digital the world
is that we live today we've got this
quote here that states it very clearly
jeffrey duel the ceo and president of
heritage financial corporation he says
the technology has made the customers a
lot stickier than they used to be and i
think that's playing to our advantage as
we've watched how customers manage
through the pandemic it gave us a bit
more confidence to take the actions that
we are sure maybe that's true i'd argue
though it's because most young people
they're not going and putting all their
money in the legacy banking financial
system instead what are they doing
they're adopting new digital
technologies they've got apps like
paypal venmo cash app strike and many
many others they also are adopting
things like bitcoin and they're saying
that legacy system that legacy monetary
policy that's led by humans it's
screwing me over it's not helpful the
payment rails are antiquated and
outdated and the monetary policy simply
continues to force me to lose purchasing
power on an annual basis instead what
i'm going to do is i'm going to use new
banking rails new payment rails that's
where you see the mobile apps come in
it's where you see all these new
fintechs take hold on top of that they
say i need new monetary policy as well i
want to protect my purchasing power i
don't want to have it lost year over
year at two three four five six seven
percent instead what i'm going to do is
i'm going to opt out i'm not going to
complain about the old system anymore
i'm simply going to participate in the
new one i'm going to help build the new
one and i'm willing to bet that over the
coming decades we are going to see this
younger generation as they grow into the
wealth of their parents and their
grandparents as they continue to make
more money and build their careers and
their financial positions in life
they're going to continue to take assets
out of the old system and put it in the
new system if these banks want to
compete shutting down the bank branches
is only step one they're gonna have to
figure out how to integrate these new
digital technologies into their
workflows into their products and into
their services or these banks are toast